اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من خان يونس اهلا
بكم عشرات الشهداء في قصف اسرائيلي على
جبال شمالي قطاع غزه وتعذر الوصول الى
المصابين لاسعافه وشهداء في قصف استهدف
منطقه ماهوله بالسكان في مخيم البريج وسط
القطاع والجزيره ترصد حجم الدمار وتكدس
جثث الشهداء في شوارع حي تل الزعتر بعد
انسحاب الاحتلال ومنعه طواقم الاسعاف من
التحرك
اشتباكات ضاريه بين قوات الاحتلال وفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في شمال ووسط وجنوب
القطاع كتائب القسام تعلن ايقاع عدد كبير
من جنود الاحتلال بين قتيل وجريح في
جباليا وجحر الديك وتدمير خمس دبابات
باعاده تصنيع صاروخين اسرائيليين لم
ينفجرا وسرايا القدس تعلن قنص جنود
اسرائيليين شمالي القطاع وتقارير
اسرائيليه تقول ان جيش الاحتلال يستعد
لانهاء العمليه البريه خلال اسابيع وبدء
مرحله جديده اقل
كثافه وصط تصعيد اسرائيلي مستمر في الضفه
الغربيه قوات الاحتلال تقتحم مدينه جنين
وتحاصر مخيمها باكثر من 18 اليه عسكريه
قبل ان تنسحب منه وتشن حمله اعتقالات في
قلنديا ودهشه وعقبه جبر وتصاعد حالات
الاعدام الميداني التي ينفذها
الاحتلال جيش الاحتلال يقول انه قصف مجمعا
عسكريا ومواقع وبنى تحتيه تابعه لحزب الله
في جنوب لبنان وغارات اسرائيليه على بلده
كفر كلا وحزب الله يقول ان اثنين من
مقاتليه استشهد في مواجهات مع القوات
الاسرائيليه ومصدر في المقاومه الاسلاميه
في العراق يقول انها استهدفت منصه حقل
كاريش للغاز في البحر المتوسط الى
اللقاء
n